it felt pretty scary I must admit I had
a good in in preparation for the role
was probably the most scared I've ever
been in going into any movie but it's
one of those lovely things it's the day
before first day of work is always
petrifying and then as soon as you get
there and you realize that everyone is
actually lovely and it's not
yeah and that um the character that we
created for this Sarah Connor is so
different to Linda's and not that I mean
the the circumstance which we find her
in is so different to Linda what Linda
and James Cameron created that there was
a lot of room to kind of to put my own
mark on it and which made it less
daunting there was lots of physical
attributes that sarah has that I don't
at all so it was it was it was a
brilliant couple of months of getting to
grips with guns and making that feel
like I had done it for ten years and
then those guns are pretty heavy so a
lot of strength training to just to just
simply be able to to have the skill set
that Sarah does so it was brilliant
because in one sense it's um it's it's
kind of it's it's a it's a great skill
to learn but more than anything it was a
way of me getting into Sarah Connors
shoes yeah it was pretty surreal he is
incredibly iconic and so there was a lot
of fear and trepidation in coming up to
that first meeting but then he just puts
everyone at ease soon as he walks into
the room he's just so easygoing and
relaxed and comfortable in his own skin
and that in turn makes everyone else
comfortable as a girl hates it it was
more getting to see his professionalism
on camera because whilst working out and
doing guns is something that obviously I
will do for this world and for others
I'm an actor first and foremost and so
getting to see the way that he is so
professional on set and how he handles
people on set that was kind of the most
inspiring thing it was really good again
same age coming at it from this sort of
from the new standpoint so we were very
much like yeah Brothers in Arms in that
sense because you've got Arnold who
created the Terminator he knows his way
around that set who knows his way around
that character and then we kind of
newbies turn up and sort of a trying to
reprise these roles so it was it was it
was gorgeous it was just love
lots of banter lots of fun yeah it's
brilliant I mean any time that you
anytime that anyone's flagging on set
which sometimes happens you're doing
long hours and right you know when you
reach their reach their a halfway point
they kind of just have to summon even
more strength but when you look around
you know you know you've got an amazing
ensemble to back you up and when someone
was falling someone else was coming in
to kind of help boost morale and get the
energy levels back up again it was just
so lucky it turns it on its head in that
it is very much a continuation of the
much-beloved
one and to that James came and created
but giving the characters an entire new
backstory situations circumstance so
that you see a whole you see them in a
whole new light and you see those
relationships turned on their heads and
so whilst the the characters are still
exactly the same the parts of them that
you see are totally different so I think
that's one of the that's one of the
biggest things and and the fact that
it's um it's a terminator franchise it's
it's got the stunts it's got the action
but it's got a huge amount of heart and
sensitivity as well it allows Sarah
Connor to be both badass and human which
i think is a really important aspect
especially for me coming into the role
to try and make the differences between
what I'm what I've done and what Linda
Hamilton did as well is that you you see
a much more sensitive human attribute
through the eyes of the relationship
between father and daughter and and it's
incredibly special when she she watched
you know it starts pretty dark she
watched her parents Jahi when she's nine
years old to be saved by this man by
this Terminator who then promises to
save her forever never and ever
so that's a kind of a pretty strong bond
it starts as as people are ready for it
starts with with a hark back to what has
already been and then you get the huge
change especially as Sarah Khan is
introduced you get that whole set up but
then it's an enormous role reversal so
the the kind of the look on on Kyle
Reese's face when he's sort of this is
not what he was expecting at all that
that that changes brilliant and then
jumping forward to the new threat the
threat that we that
that we are now aware of and then when
you get there to have the savior of
humankind turn out to be the savior and
salvation of Skynet's
is another huge twist that uh that just
projects this movie and and it just kind
of has this movie never stop and just
keeps going I think to see the the the
homage and their respect that we've paid
to the first two but to also see those
new relationships and to see a bloody
kick-ass girl not be a damsel in
distress but but save but save someone
else's life which is pretty fun
you